this is
valkyray also known as ray-ray
rar xd oh no ma'am
you know i realized everything's kind of
blowing up you know with these orgs and
stuff reaching out to me
i realized like wow this is actually
happening
uh last year my dad passed away from
cancer
and that whole year for six months i was
taking care of him by myself
it was the hardest time of my life and
you guys really like stuck around and
helped me through that
i know it's already a lot of people so
every time i know i've been doing this
for so long but every time i stream i
still get nervous
[Music]
oh my god that's so crazy four foot nine
are you trolling four five you're
kidding you're like 5'3 i think
are you ready for something new
[Music]
before she was part of a squad of
streamers playing among us with a member
of the us congress
and aoc what have you been doing this
round i was in the upper
left part of the map and
i don't know before she became the first
female content creator to join hundred
thieves
she fits our brand so well we have to go
and get her and i'm really glad that we
were able to put this together and make
it happen
and even before she made a name for
herself playing fortnite
last second
[Music]
we missed the whole last game rachel
valkyrie hofstetter was holding down
three
jobs trying to make it through community
college
one of those jobs was a gig at gamestop
where valkyrie could indulge her
lifelong passion for video games
as she mentioned in the short
autobiographical video with hundred
thieves
so yeah i was playing games my whole
life and then i was going to school
i went to community college and i got my
transfer degree because i didn't know
what i wanted to do yet with my life and
so i was working
at a car wash i was working at a bank
and then i picked up a job at gamestop
valkyrie found video games to be a
welcome distraction
from a difficult family dynamic when she
was growing up her parents often argued
and the fights were exacerbated by her
father's drinking problem
i think my mom really encouraged me to
play games is because
since my dad was an alcoholic and they
were always fighting i
i think they would feel bad my mom was a
housewife
and my dad was the one that was working
every day
and so they always fight every night
when we come home and he's drunk
and then my mom just wanted us to be
happy so she would just buy us whatever
we wanted and i just always wanted video
games
so i think she just really wanted my
sister and i to
just be happy and she carried her love
of video games
into adulthood eager to share her
favorite thing with a like-minded
community
valkyrie started an instagram account
where she posted about the game she was
playing
upcoming game releases and pictures of
her retro consoles
as her following on instagram grew to
well over 15
000 she considered uploading some of her
gaming exploits to youtube
but it wasn't long before her followers
convinced her to give twitch a go
and then i thought that well that seems
easier i don't have to
record and edit and upload i could just
stream so
then i did and then here we are four
years later
while many streamers follow trends to
gain subs on twitch
valkyrie just wanted to enjoy a variety
of her favorite titles
games like dark souls and the walking
dead i liked having people that wanted
to be there for me
rather than for a particular game and so
it was very interesting like i'd always
switch games and there would be like a
set group of people that would always
follow me and then new people would come
in
six months later valkyrie was regularly
streaming to a few hundred people
and made a decision to quit all of her
other jobs
to focus on her twitch channel when i
quit my last job gamestop
i went full-time streaming for it's been
three and a half years now
i think and i was chilling doing it
full-time you know i
averaged 200 400 viewers doing variety
but everything changed when fortnight
came out valkyrie tried the battle
royale title
at the suggestion of her chat and was
instantly addicted
brick all the loot fell
this poor guy
off the wall
yeah i went off i went off as her
viewership numbers jumped into the
thousands
valkyrie found herself with offers from
various different orgs
who wanted to bring her on board and
ultimately
valkyrie settled on a last minute bid
from hundred thieves
you know i realized everything's kind of
blowing up and you know with these orgs
and stuff reaching out to me
um i realized like wow this is actually
happening
and then you guys hit me up at the last
second
and change the game from the outside
looking in
valkyrie's story was one of a meteoric
rise to stardom
she was living the dream but behind the
scenes
she was dealing with a profound loss
about a year before valkyrie's fortnite
exploits made her
a twitch superstar her father lost a
battle to cancer
the money valkyrie earned from her
stream allowed her to take care of him
when he was ill
while the supportive community she built
helped her to get through
the toughest period of her life last
year
my dad passed away from cancer
and that whole year or six months i was
taking care of him by myself
it was the hardest time of my life and
um you guys really like stuck around and
helped me through that
and like now because of you guys i'm
able to help my mom
so like you're helping me
and other people as well and valkyrie's
devotion to her family
didn't end there supporting her mom
became the streamer's inspiration
to continue to reach for the stars some
of you know that i take care of my mom
full time she lost her job
um three years ago and ever since she
lost her job three years ago i've been
taking care of her
entirely my mom is pretty much my baby
now
but valkrade didn't start streaming to
make money she did it because
she genuinely loved video games and that
sincerity along with her willingness to
be candid about the ups and downs in her
life
quickly garnered valkyrie even more fans
this past twitch con since the blow up
was
very insane i've been to previous
twitchcons but this past
year i had two or three meet and greets
all like two hours and we had to cap the
line because there was so many people
and it just like i never really realized
how many people actually know who i am
and
are following me and there were plenty
of ups for valkyrie to share
she moved into hundred thieves tricked
out content house
in l.a ray what's your favorite spot um
honestly this is quite the view
oh i'm actually really liking this
balcony right now balcony very nice
and she got to do the things she loved
most for a living
valkyrie's life was rife with
possibilities
but things can't stay the same forever
[Music]
in january 2020 the streamer signed an
exclusive agreement
with youtube a move that allowed her to
not only secure a steady paycheck
and keep all of her content in one place
but also gave her the creative freedom
to branch out now that i made the switch
to youtube i feel like i can
focus on not just gaming but focus on
other interests that i had as well like
beauty fashion fitness health and
wellness
and just whatever it is vlogging
traveling
all of it i feel like i can do anything
now about a month later
valkrei moved out of hundred thieves
house and into her own place
she continued making content for the org
but wanted to be able to separate
her work and her private life so um as
some of you know
matt nadeshot jack courage and brooke
live at the content house which is five
minutes away from here i wanted to
separate
my work life from my at-home life a bit
so that's why i have like my laptop here
and stuff so
i come home i get away from my computer
i'm starting to focus more on like
health and wellness and fitness as well
on top of moving house moving from
twitch to youtube
came with its own set of obstacles but
in spite of many tears being shed along
the way
valkyrie never stopped being her lovable
genuine self so i just take some of this
eye shadow stuff and just dump it around
my eyes
i guess i just don't care enough i don't
know i guess i just don't care enough
to learn how to do make it's like not a
hobby of mine
and in the summer of 2020 valkyrie hit a
significant milestone
in her career 1 million youtube
subscribers
refresh what i wanted to see it changed
by itself but
nicole vera thank you for joining
oh my god that's so crazy
valkyrie also made the decision to move
in with several
other prominent female streamers
including pokemane
i actually don't know how tall i am
actually i don't know
anymore either oh my god it doesn't
matter if my head's not showing
i bought this just for this one
you're four foot nine
since the move valkyrie has been
spending most of her time playing
twitch's latest multiplayer craze
among us and one of those games turned
out to be
historic in an effort to reach younger
voters
a u.s congresswoman alexandria
ocasio-cortez
put out a call on twitter for anyone
who'd play among us with her on stream
valkyrie joined a squad of other popular
streamers like pokemane
disguise toast dr lupo and a few others
for what turned out to be the third most
watched
individual stream in twitch's history
one more kill one more kill one more
kill
[Applause]
using her influence to hype up a female
politician's campaign
is right on brand for valkyray who's
made it a point to feature
other female streamers in her videos to
help represent women
in the gaming community and valkyrie
seems to have
no plans to slow down anytime soon
her youtube channel currently sits at
over 2 million subscribers
more than double the number she had in
june 2020
making her the fastest growing live
streamer in the world
right now i got it guys i win i can't
believe i won
valkyrie faced her fair share of
adversity
family troubles building her streaming
career from the ground
up and more but through it all she
managed to never lose sight
of who she really was and if her
phenomenal channel growth is anything to
go by
valkyray is definitely here to stay
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell
for unique bite-sized videos you won't
find anywhere else
hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages